combien d'élèves par rapport à la guerre
et qu'il faut absolument les observer et
donc ce qui se passe aujourd'hui depuis
le français en début février par à la
coalition syrienne gouvernementales dans
le nord de la syrie c'est une guerre
totale une guerre que briser toutes les
règles par rapport au droit
international humanitaire par rapport
aussi vous dirai juste à l'humanité de
façon générale la grande bataille pour
l'organisation médecins sans frontières
et pour d'autres ong qui travaillent sur
la ligne de front c'est s'assurer qu'on
va être capable de sauvegarder je dirais
cette part d'humanité là sur le fait qu'
on va respecter le droit à l'accès aux
soins
sur la ligne de front est ce que je
trouve encore le pire et le plus
inacceptable c'est le fait que parce que
ça se répète donc faut quand même se
dire que là depuis le début de 2016
les u17 hôpitaux qui ont été attaqués en
syrie dont 5 de msf
et c'est pas parce que ça se passe à
tous les jours que ça devient la
nouvelle norme et donc il faut
absolument se battre contre cette
nouvelle réalité là et ne pas accepter
que ce soit les nouvelles règles du jeu
un moment donné je crois qu'il faut dire
qu'une ligne qui était dépassé une ligne
rouge et il faut remettre les pendules à
l'heure et je je je ne peux pas croire
qu'on ne partage pas cette cesser ces
valeurs humanitaires la cette humanité
là qui a des règles de guerre que les
citoyens que des civils ont droit à
l'accès aux soins parce que c'est alors
pendant justement dans ces moments là
qu'on a besoin de ces soins là